there are no apologies that i'm aware of
has anybody heard from councillor arnold
i mean either um you'll notice that our
first submitter isn't due until 20 past
um but that gives us a chance to go over
the process for the next
couple of days from
my perspective it would be really useful
if you remember that when submitters
have finished giving their their
presentation
that we had to ask questions uh not make
statements
um it'll help the the process go a lot
quicker
um rhiannon do you want to give us an
overview
of the process please
thank you chair moreno councillors um
you might need to pull that microphone a
little closer
is that better thank you um
so we've got the hearings today and
tomorrow we've had for
540 submitters you should all have
received an updated version of the
hearing timetable which emily's been
working really hard to put together for
you to try and minimize the number of
gaps
there are a few so we start
um today and run through until 2 30 when
um you have a brief break before
extraordinary
ppp and extraordinary is and then we
start again tomorrow morning and run all
day
so each submitter will have
10 minutes there's five minutes for them
to speak and then five minutes for you
to ask questions we do have to keep
quite strictly two times so to help that
um georgia and amelie have a little
buzzer which they will
sound and that will just help um
councillor low with the
um chairing of the meeting um
so we have the um report
here and i just want to really recognize
all the people that
worked really hard over three days a lot
of late nights to get this out to you
um talini mera georgia emily
really worked really really hard it's a
huge huge
job um so you can see the cover report
has
a brief summary for you for the um
for the feedback that we had in the
submissions
then also georgia has put together a
table
for you of the summary of submission so
that's tab 1.1
on your board books agenda um so that
contains
each submission and a color coding for
the main
issues so green means that the
submitter preferred the preferred option
orange means that they preferred
under the second option or grey that
they had no preference
read was that um council should do
nothing
i'll just note that the numbers
are not fully in order so when we
removed duplicates etc
that's why there is more than 541
numbers within the board books
so don't don't worry if you see 575
etcetera they are all in there um
in tabling this report today or just ask
if you would receive
the late submissions so in addition to
the four that are named
within your agenda
we've also received five within the last
couple of days which
um you've got copies of so that's from
wendy baker bronwyn caldwell
linda bell colin anderson and daryl
jenkins
so i would also recommend that you
receive those
late submissions probably covers
off the process for the hearings thanks
rhiannon any questions for rhiannon at
this point councillors
any questions of the process
just with that um 10 minutes and they'll
get the the buzz
at five and another one at 10. if the
submitter chooses to use the entire 10
minutes to
speak that's that's their prerogative it
does however
take away the opportunity for us to ask
questions
they'll be reminded of that if they
go long councillor pottinger will the
chair be tolerating statements dressed
up as questions
it depends on how you want to tolerate
um
very clever ones not really
making a statement and going do you
agree yeah is is not an
uh is not a question um
so again save the statements for when we
get to
actually uh debating at the end of this
agree and please don't take offense if i
um just remind you
the other thing i'll be reminding
everybody of is to make sure that
they're speaking into their microphones
um for those people who are on zoom uh
there was the motion we need a motion to
receive the late submissions as that's
correct yes thanks ryan moved councillor
sopa secretary councillor abbott
put that all in favor aye against
carried
chair i think you also just need to
receive all the submissions ah thank you
councillor abbott and seconded
councillor lewis
so that's all the other ones backdoor
now we've um
received the late ones now they're all
being received put that all in favor
aye against kerry
thank you uh we have 10 minutes we we
don't have
mr mclean here a chance do we we do
do you mind coming up early excellent
pop on up to the table
um just just yep absolutely and if you
make sure that when you're speaking you
speak into the microphone
you've got 10 minutes we'll give you a
bell at five
and another one at 10. um if you want to
uh use the entire 10 minutes that does
narrow the time for for counselors to
ask
questions um counselors have had a
chance to read through
uh your submission um so really it's
over here now thank you very much for
your submission and for coming along
this morning
is it working all right here we go
oh thank you allowing me to speak and
just uh yeah thanks for your service to
the city because i do travel the country
a lot and
it's always love coming back to
invercargill with the
wide roads and the green spaces and the
fresh air as well which is
is good and definitely a city with heart
also notice the ltp is very conservative
with debt
which is smart and appreciated
and also the inner city upgrade is
fantastic as well
as once in a lifetime opportunity and
it's been taken which is
which is great i just got two messages
today um first one is to
support developers to allow subdivision
development around green spaces
and make it to make it a great place to
raise a family
and the second one is to not waste
money redoing the museum
the first point is i feel the council
needs to support developers who develop
subdivisions
um invercargill has some great green
spaces
you know as i understand the largest
amount per capita
in the southern hemisphere and so it's
just it's time to make sure
invercargill can continue to grow and
enjoy these green spaces
um subdivisions are filling up and i
think we just need to
have an open mindset to support
developers
to develop land around these green
spaces
an example being is and now just live
down the center town so i
um around this area so this could have
jumped out at me but this
and bainfield road there's paddington
arms
and there's some land zone rural that
isn't really productive as rural land
and it's not
been enjoyed by the public
[Music]
whereas it could be developed into a
subdivision and have hundreds of
families enjoy that
area to golf had a golf ball the rugby
park to
kick the ball around feed the ducks at
donovan park
or enjoy the soon to be upgraded
anderson house all within walking
distance
um there's likely other examples around
town as well but that was just
one one to point out and i just support
those three of those six
particularly three of those six guiding
principles in the ldp which is
the city to inhabit and enjoy um
and restore a healthy connection with
environment so you get to enjoy those
green spaces
and move for prosperity and health so
definitely believe in
easy access to nice places to walk and
bike and
exercise so just in summary as i guess
have
to have an open mindset to support the
developers and
developing subdivisions around those
green spaces to make invercargill a
great place to inhabit and enjoy
second point is one to make was just i
don't believe it's a responsible concept
to spend that much money doing up a
museum
i fully support the concept of the
museum it's a
great place for children and adults to
spend family time and also to an
attraction for visitors to the city
um here i see 53 million dollars to
update an
old asset that
is already been updated and redone
improved three times um and we're at
this stage again
it's hard to upgrade and update an old
building you're always constrained by
the existing structure
and space and design and with all
renovations you end up destroying
perfectly good workable assets in the
process of renovation which
um you spend money taking that down
so i i just
i reckon the best way to go is a new
build
but i reckon there's a smarter way to do
it i don't have the answers
um
[Music]
yeah i'd read through the art gallery
south museum and art gallery report and
it was it was very well thought out
and it puts out the new build at 75
million um
i'll just encourage the counts
councillors to look at
ways to decrease the cost to bring it
down to
a more sort of acceptable level
with the building i guess is three
common ways you can
decrease cost you can build less a
smaller footprint
you can downgrade your specifications
or three have a sort of a smarter divine
design and bring some innovation into it
i reckon definitely the smarter design
and innovation is the way to go
i reckon looking at a building that's
probably a
lot simpler structure but with some
innovation that gives us its own
identity
um would make a very good council asset
and also a very good place for
the um paths in public to go to
um what obviously i don't really have
detail exactly around it however i think
it's
worth looking into further
um it's a bit of a poor illustration but
if you're looking to upgrade in your own
house you can you know renovate or look
to do a new build
um when you're renovating
you're sort of constrained within your
section you're on and the
design of your house and your budget
when you go to sort of design a new
build
you probably got a bit of an idea of
your dream home you're going to build
and you start drawing it up and you
start getting costs and
it's always a lot more than you think
um so i just
reckon possibly that could be with the
new with the museum with the new build
you there's always lots of great ideas
and lots of
things we want to add to it to make it a
awesome place
but i reckon adding the constraint of a
uh more responsible budget and giving it
back to the
architects to come up with a design that
is within a
more responsible budget is the way to go
in um
yeah just keep and keep within those six
guiding principles as well
um i reckon could be looked at so i
guess
in summary i do support the idea of a
museum
um however would prefer a
new build and with a smarter budget to
work to
so that's all ahead and thanks for
listening and
trust you will get the wisdom and the
answers and fulfilling the long-term
plan
thank you mr maclean for your submission
uh it's open for questions councillor
pottinger and then councillor amundsen
um thank you for that my questions uh
regarding
uh your your very sensible comments
around the museum uh two things
the pyramid is that important to to even
retain the concept if we did build new
and the other question is location
if you were building you would you take
the time to think is this the right
place
um i did think about the location
i reckon the current location as the
best location go to another location
there's always
a lot more unseen cost and a lot more
can be
time can be added because the resource
consents etc
um pyramid on
not too fast either way but yeah yeah no
thanks for that but i do think it's
probably good to have some
identity or you know it's
not just a plain building but yeah yeah
yeah thank you councillor emerson that
was my question
thank you um when you're talking about
support for developers around green
spaces uh what sort of support do you
think councils should consider
uh probably more just i don't want to
sound wrong with open mindset to so
that for instance that area is zoned
rural and in the council plan
that's to but um what's going through
but the
over arching city plan is to protect
rural spaces
so i reckon however that rural space
isn't useful as a rural
space exactly and it's not been enjoyed
as a
green space um so just because it was
zoned rural
changing it to be able to be built into
residential doesn't mean we're
exactly destroying rural space my book
but i'm not thinking of financial
assistance but just
making the progress just around the
concept and just to make clear i don't
have any
plans as a developer or friends of the
developer or
had an agenda there yeah
councillor lewis thank you very much
listen kane thank you for your
presentation it's
interesting um downsizing the museum and
making it more efficient
whatever the exact words what would we
do with all the extra
displays which are contained within the
building would we need
an extra building to contain all those
do you think with that extra cost
um i wasn't so much so i wouldn't make
clear
what i'm saying i wasn't so much
thinking of downsizing it
but having a um
whenever you put a like you put a budget
around something and you've got to work
to it it brings out innovation
so whether it's different building types
or
materials being used or designed um
yeah because 50 million at 5 000 square
meters is 10 000
a square meter roughly which i think's
um
it's it's a good amount for a commercial
um public space but yeah i'm not
thank you thank you uh councillor lewis
just a reminder that you tend to turn
your head when you're talking to
somebody just take your microphone with
you that'd be awesome
uh mr mclean thank you very much for
your submission uh it's considered thank
you also
for um answering the questions that
we've had for you this morning
thanks i thank you all for your time and
if you put into it
appreciate it thank you
gordon you've arrived in just the neck
of time if you don't mind going up a
couple of minutes early
there's a microphone there if you can
just make sure that you're pointing the
the head at it that would be useful
counselors have had a chance to read the
submission just a reminder there's this
10 minutes for you to speak to it and
we'll give you a ballot five
um and if you try and make sure there's
some time left for counsellors to ask
questions that would be awesome
okay thanks gordon it's yours i'm sure i
won't take 10 minutes
um so my name is gordon crombee and i'm
president of the
wahopai association football club um so
hope i is an incorporated society and
our purpose is to provide footballing
opportunities
um either as a player an administrator
coach referee volunteer parent etc
um we're based at surrey park and our
club rooms
are in the grand stand um currently we
have
over 100 playing members senior men's
and women's
and junior boys and girls those
membership numbers don't include
special olympians who we have a
footballing program with
and students at new river primary who we
also have a footballing program with
that's about to get underway we request
that the icc
delays any decision regarding the future
plans for the grandstand
until such time as further information
is able to be supplied
to the users of the facility and the
council
this is due to the lack of the specific
details contained in the surrey park
redevelopment business case which does
not allow
waihopi afc and other users to make in
the
informed choice as to which of the
options is preferable
and requesting that any decision be
delayed i hope iafc
also requests that the current budgeted
amount of 1.5 million
under option one is ring fenced to
ensure that this is available in the
future
for whatever redevelopment is undertaken
why hope i believes that further
consultation amongst user groups of
surrey park greenstand
and the city council is required to
develop an understanding of
what is required in both the short and
the long term
using information and recommendations
contained in the
icc surrey park redevelopment business
case the oem planning
group surrey park future report and the
south and regional splat
spaces and places strategy
hopefully is mindful of the fact that a
request for the delaying of the
indecision
pushes out the time frame for any
redevelopment but we believe that by
doing so
all parties will be able to develop a
solution that
best meets the needs of our community
longer term
so a little bit of history too about
wahhabi i hope i um is currently based
the club rooms as i said in the
grandstand and we have um
fields inside the athletics track
and we also have fields
where the softball redevelopment has
taken place but we are about to move
from there
over to back behind stadium southland
and beside
escort community school well i hope i
used to be based behind
the stadium in the fields behind
stadium southland we our club rooms were
demolished to make way for the velodrome
and
following that we moved to where we are
now
so now we're facing that option of maybe
having to move
again um and obviously moving over
over to where the softball development
is wouldn't be preferable
because then we'd actually be further
away from our future grounds
um so that's our case
thank you for the opportunity any
questions that's right
um thanks gordon uh the delay that
you're seeking how long
have you a suggestion how long the
council would need to delay for
well i suppose that's um undetermined
yet until we
um are able to have a look at the
southland spaces and places strategy
talk with the other user groups so
obviously ethylex southland
and the two athletics clubs um primary
school and secondary school sports
i think there's something like 14
schools in invercargill with
roles over 300 so when they are having
um you athletic a grandstand needs to be
able to accommodate those 300 students
plus
parents teachers um support staff from
the school and their families
so you know there's a lot of work to be
done around the actual
amount of usage that grandstanding
itself receives and other groups that
use it
besides athletics and football as well
um other groups do use it when there's
something on at stadium south and for
example
like basketball tournaments and they use
our
club rooms and changing rooms because
there's an overflow from the stadium
so i think there's quite a bit of work
to be done but i think there's an
exciting opportunity as well
around working with the two athletics
clubs and
football club on a shared facility
so the additional information that
you're looking for is more around the
feedback from those other user groups
yes
yeah and looking at you know
recommendations from the
um spaces and places strategy
thank you councillors any other
questions councillor pottinger
thank you chair um my questions is
around the
location of that grand stand now that we
have the stadium big stadium build
it it gets a i personally i see a bottle
neck right on that corner of your map
massive trucks trying to get round the
back
do you see here and then on the sports
days you see these massive crowds of
kids and everything trying to get in
there do you see the actual current
location there's a bit of a problem
i mean it's north facing but yes no um i
think it's facing the right way
but i think there is opportunities for
the grandstand to be moved over
more towards ascot community school
and possibilities for a road for example
to come through from
pay street to go around where the
softball car park
currently is and that would allow
obviously allow trucks
to be able to enter and exit from tay
street
um obviously that would require work
with their
latest clubs as well if the green stand
was to move over there's one
um atheist club right fairly close to
the existing grandstand
um and the other
efforts club is a bit further around um
so
i think a smaller grandstand but um
obviously
depends what a basic green stand means
as well
um now we believe that it requires um
not only a roof but sides to it as well
and changing facilities and club rooms
underneath
whether that is able to incorporate
athletics club rooms as well i mean
it's those further discussions that have
to be had with their perks
no thanks yeah appreciate that thank you
further questions counselors councillor
clark
yeah gordon um so just to clear and
answer that i've been involved with the
waihope for decades and decades and just
building on what uh my colleagues said
about the
about the access it is a problem even in
the current situation isn't it
so on on soccer days even though there's
not a lot of people in the grandstand
the
access to that facility is difficult
isn't it yes it is i think
earlier this year when right at the
start of the season
and i think there was obviously um
junior softball was on
um we we talked with athletics to make
sure we're not holding things on the
same day because that would just be
impossible but there was
i think there may have been a couple of
things on the stadium southend as well
and
um i parked over in the existing
software car park knowing that i
wouldn't be able to get anywhere near
the football
so two more quick questions just
building on what you suggested about the
access way down the um from tay street
down the
east side of the stadium which is going
into where queen's park currently is and
going further right down to this
stadium that you occupy if there was a
road there
and if there were car parks behind the
stadium which is where you queen's park
has its current ground and why hope i
used to have this ground
would that be a better facility for you
if you
subsequently have the fields where the
softball currently is if you can
understand all of that
yeah we are going to get those fields so
yeah currently we've been talking
um with the council and um how one of
our training fields is going
um we have removed the diamonds yeah
um and we're the softball the old
softball club room with clint and
queen's park club rumors
that will be demolished in a playing
field um
we laid down there and also
there's an existing playing field behind
stadium south and running parallel with
tay street sure um that tends to get a
bit boggy so we'll probably prefer
the other two but i think there still is
room um
to have that road from tay street
through the existing car park up besides
the side of it basically there is
already part of a road there
behind the stadium and
i mean there's some storage containers
here as well and there's
still room for those storage containers
um with the road
and i'm not so sure if there'd be room
for car parking there maybe
we'd have to see the layout um of the
plane
how the playing field's laid out once
that old club rooms had been removed
sure but the car parks could be on the
right behind the velodrome now
which is just currently like you say a
very boggy soccer ground doesn't it
yes it is yeah last question for you
i'll be really quick on this
you asked for a delay um our long-term
plan is reviewed every three years
is that too long or would you like the
delay to be shorter or longer than that
i think you know to get some certainty
you know obviously some
older club members are a bit concerned
about what's going to
be happening um and probably from an
athletics point of view too they want
a bit of certainty around um
bidding for hosting rights they've got
the colgate games
next season um or this yeah the next
season
um so probably yeah earlier than
within the next three years okay thank
you
thank you any further questions
if not thanks for the submission gordon
and thanks for turning up to speak to it
this morning and answering the questions
thank you council and thank you
everybody for the opportunity
mark young are you presents welcome
along
thanks for your submission time's yours
thank you councillors
uh can council ludlow you worship and
you're the fellow councillors my name's
mark young
i'm a long-term city resident i think we
moved here when i was three
so almost lifelong
i first want to explain i've got a brain
injury so
if my submission is a bit
iffy it's because what i think of my
brain
quite often doesn't go down into my
hands um
so it might be a bit all over the place
and everything like that but
typical brain injury i have a lot of
anxiety i'm an isolationist
so for me to be here is a big thing
um now especially given what's happened
in the last
year and a half worldwide to me
this plan is where you as a council
decide whether you're going to be
transformational or you're going to keep
going
the way we've gone over the last five
six seven decades when nothing really
happens
and the thing for me is
these decisions and being
transformational is from the top
down not the bottom up because
people like me can complain and complain
and complain
and nothing gets done it's you who make
the decisions so you've got to decide
are you going to be transformational
or you're just going to keep
invercargill exactly the same as it is
now my submission specifically to do
with the cbd and the development around
the mall
and whilst having a player in the cbd
would be great
to me what is more an urgent need is a
suitable area for large gatherings
stages really activities outdoor
activities which draw the people
back into the cbd now both this master
plan
and the 2011 master plan stated wachner
place does not work effectively
and now we have the ideal opportunity to
close
s street off completely and make a
pedestrian part of them all
getting rid of the cars and developing
the retail shops on the north side of s
street so that they actually become
part of the mall and that's done
just by allowing full pedestrian access
to the whole street
this means events can be held in this
street marker stalls
buskers increase seating over the whole
street
far more people will come to s street to
have lunch and therefore
all the retail shops will have a far
better option of good food traffic
with over 500 extra car parks that 20 or
30 in this street
become irrelevant simply because within
about two minutes walking from s street
there will be two car parking buildings
two council parks and estimaton street
plus
all the metered parking in the cbd plus
the new car park now
i got figures from the council that's
about
2100 car parks within the cbd
and saving 30 car parks
when you can close off s street to me
makes far more sense
for too long the emphasis has been on
what retailers want
and especially when it comes to parking
in this street
cars do not buy products people do
and to include the north street of s
north side of s
street and will increase their foot
traffic dramatically
the isthmus group developed the city
mall in christchurch and i'm sure they
heard exactly the same complaints from
helen steins and valentine's and all
those that were affected
that they must have parking outside
their shops to survive
yet they thrived without the cars and in
the end
the city mall now goes all the way to
the avon
now they didn't close that off for some
funny reason
obviously the city mall works
and to me converting
our s street into a pedestrian friendly
place what far preferable to people
sitting in their lunch rooms to come to
somewhere where they can sit there are
no
cars it's it's pedestrian friendly
for too long we have almost every five
years heard the call about what to do
with their street
for almost five decades now we've had
report after report generated at massive
cost
and nothing really has been done we've
gone from putting a roof over to mate
over to make it a one sorry putting a
roof
over it to making it a one way by
closing off
right turning traffic at indeed street
from d street
and now it seems you want to turn right
train right turning
reinstated you were going back
to what we used to have that's not
progress
the council possibly spent a few hundred
thousand dollars renewing the center
strip when we
got rid of the right turning and putting
in the plinths and now the best you can
come up with is demolish
the plants and we
bring in the um right turning into
western this is not future purifying
this is stepping back
decades to what we used to do for some
reason councils over the decades have
been
fixated on cars parking and narrowing
the widest streets in new zealand
the days of the car are almost gone of
the combustion engine
20 of all cars built in the world last
year were electric
and that's increasing exponentially
every year we now have major
manufacturers whose
volvo ford um
jaguar and land rover are now saying by
2030 they will
only build electric cars even hybrids
are gone
now when you've got big manufacturers
like that
coming out with statements like that
other manufacturers are only going to
follow
so the day of the car is almost gone
and while most main cities are
increasing their public transport
we have decreased ours to such an extent
where only a tiny percentage of the
population uses it
so if in 25 years most of the cars are
gone all the parking buildings meet at
park and will become
a deducted now is the time when we're
developing the whole block
to make a stand a stand for the people
and not cars
people buy the products that keep the
retail sector alive
not cars your job is not to look 10
years in the future but 30 or 40 giving
this part of history back to the people
which we
good future proofing that benefits not
the few but the many
now there was a report about cutting tay
street from two lanes
per side to one why this obsession with
narrowing our nice white streets into
the envy of
most cities in new zealand it is a
narrow-minded view that has been
very poorly thought out at the moment in
excess of 300
heavy trucks and i'm talking 40 to 60
ton
trucks are coming milk tankers logging
trucks fertilizer trucks and trait
trucks
rumble through our cbd with most turning
left at clyde street
to proceed to our bluff if you're even
contemplating narrowing tay street then
a mandatory heavy traffic bypass needs
to be in place first
heavy traffic bypasses have been on the
council's radar for years yet nothing
has been done about
it why what other cities allow these
trucks in their cbd
the crescent was converted from two
lanes to one and
look at what it's like now anyone from
traveling from 11th street quite often
finds traffic back round to the railway
hotel
and to get to the corner or of tay
street and d street
can be a nightmare simply because one
lane services all directions
now if it was done to slow down traffic
well you succeeded
because now you've got at all times of
the day
traffic backed up it's just ridiculous
um
i mean if ensuring traffic flow was the
idea behind the change let the crescent
be your guide it's a big fail
keep our wide streets because if you're
really concerned with safety
then reduce the speed in the cbd and not
the flow
i think i speak of for many who are sick
and tired of the council spending
hundreds of thousand dollars
over and over again and really doing
nothing but generating
income for the companies who do the
reports
your master plan 2011 has exactly the
same concerns about waking the place and
yet
ten years later and on nothing's been
done
it's still a lonely wee place barely
being used
stop generating reports and actually do
something
because i for one am sick of and of
decades of the reports with little or no
results
the cbd is for the people and not cars
and if you make
real changes to how the cbd functions
and how it is used the people will
will come and i for one hope the next
few years council will actually do what
the people want
and not just what the retailers and
those with financial connections want
maybe even now we have such an area
someone
may decide that s street is such a great
place perhaps a roof
could go over it and fulfill the report
of decades ago
that's basically it thank you mr young
and thank you for your disclosure i've
got room for one question
councillor kit yeah thank you mark well
done congratulations
if we decided to have no vehicles in esk
street how
would the retailers get their goods in
same as they do in the
in the city mall where all deliveries
are by vans and they are allowed in at
certain times of the day
so i think city malls 7 to 9 a.m
and 4 30 to 5 30 something like that
and if the invalids wanted to shop there
how would they get in
look if you cannot fit at both ends of s
street
disabled parking in in the part that's
been blocked off
then there's something wrong we should
be able to get three or four disabled
parks at
both ends surely i mean
how many disabled parks is the mall
supposed to have because
they must have a set requirement at
disabled parks
you know if we have to get rid of three
or four
normal car parks to put in disabled car
parks then
that's what we've got to do you know
it's
i had an award discussion with one of
this when i
announced presented this in in november
and this person came up to me and said
his customers
have to park outside his shop and i said
if his shop relies on his customers
parking outside
then perhaps he shouldn't be in business
and his argument was do you know who i
am and i said i know exactly who you
are getting a park in this street
is like you probably got as much chance
getting it first time round as you
as you've got of winning powerball
second time round it might be winning
lotto
but most people go round and round and
round and then give up
because it's a waste of time
thank you very much thank you mr young
and thank you for taking the time to not
only make a submission but to come along
today we really appreciate it
mr knight welcome along
morning councillors and mayor thank you
for the opportunity to
talk on the submission on behalf of
athletic southland
um i'm the chairman of athletic
southland i have been for seven years
and i've overseen quite a bit of work
done on the track and
things like that so it's a very
important
part of my community
um so a submission athletics house and
request of the invercargill city council
to delay the decision regarding the
demolition
and rebuild of the grandstand at surrey
park invercargill because of the lack of
specific detail
creating uncertainty leaving us unable
to make an informed decision about
options given
athletic southland is an incorporated
society with a running track facility
situated at surrey park we also have
storage room under the current green
stand
athletic southland's role is as an rso
and oversee the running of the athletics
in southland on behalf of the national
body athletics new zealand
we acknowledge that the demolition work
and rebuild needs
undertaking as the current grandstand is
deemed unsafe
we ask that the current funding
allocation be ring fence while this
process is undertaken so as available
for whatever
development is decided is in the best
interest of all parties
as part of the group of surrey park
users
athletic south and southland considers
it necessary to have time to investigate
the options
that meet our functional requirements
for the present and the long term ahead
of us
the proposal to have a 300 seat
grandstand
um for us is a significant decrease
it's about a third of the size of the
current grandstand
many of you would have had children down
at
the park when we've had athletic sports
days on
and the grand stand is chocker not only
with children but with grandparents
parents siblings and that sort of thing
now earlier this year when we had the
primary school sports it was a grey
drizzly day
so where does everyone go they head for
the grandstand
if it wasn't already full so you end up
with probably close to a thousand people
trying to huddle in
the grandstand a couple three or four
years ago and we had the
last colgate games down here we had rain
we ended up having to dig the long jump
put out because it was that much rain
that we couldn't actually run the long
jump and the
west end we had to actually dig
the sand over to try and get it to dry
um
people once again the grandstands
chock-a-block
we've now lost the
back facility
that people used to set up tents on
because softball had built their
building over the mound
so next year when we had the colgate
games
we've got restricted being used for
tents to be put up um
we see this as an ideal opportunity to
actually collaborate with the council
and the athletics clubs and
waihopa football and potential other
users
for instance academy southland to
actually build
a purpose-built facility there that
actually meets more than one
person's needs
it's going to take time to work through
that
proposal but i believe working with the
council is the ideal opportunity to
actually
come up with something that actually
works for the benefit of all parties
and for the benefit of surrey park not
just now
but for the next 30 years
um you know as an organization we have
an investment
it cost us 660 000 plus just
last year just to replace the track
so for us to
keep on redoing that you know we want
some certainty
as to our viability of being there
um you know the next time it needs to be
done
it'll be a top-up layer which is
somewhere in the vicinity of about
four hundred thousand dollars
and that will be in about 10 years time
hopefully i won't be uh the one doing it
but
i'll probably still be around hopefully
um
so yeah we do have significant um
investment down there while we own the
track
um we don't actually own any buildings
down there
so it's an interesting situation where
um bethesda's clubs are in their
buildings
we own the trap so um
it does need a collaborative approach
to come up with an ideal option
we at december last year had the
opportunity to invest in some new photo
finish gear
because our current photo finish gear
that we
hire from one of the members in the club
is outdated um we got the opportunity
from a u.s supplier that was struggling
with sales to
get forty thousand dollars u.s
worth of equipment for forty thousand
dollars new zealand so we saved
eighteen thousand dollars on the
currency conversion
um so we need to have somewhere that we
can permanently mount it
but some paul's club rooms doesn't cover
the finish line
so with the grandstand being a
replacement option
there's an option there that i think we
need to investigate where we actually
bring the
grandstand closer to some pools or
we look at a fully purpose-built
facility obviously each club has its own
individual needs
and concerns but the time needs to be
taken now
to investigate the options come up with
a plan and how much and
where does the money going to come from
um
so that we can actually yeah move
forward
thanks chris uh as you'll be aware what
her by afc um
submitted earlier and made a similar
request for uh
delay just around the size of covered
grandstands
at other venues around the south island
roughly how many people do they
accommodate
christchurch is about 300 that is an
open-ended
grandstand and it faces south uh
southwest
which if you've been in at the athletics
club
uh athletics track on a day there when
the weather is
crap it's actually the worst place in
christchurch they could have built that
track but
because of the weather comes from all
directions
around the port hills and it is a very
cold
hole when the weather is terrible
basically that was built because that's
what the money had
um athletics new zealand have put us i
have written a letter of support
to you guys stating that
300 would actually inhibit our
ability to hold national level events
a grand stand of only 300
so you know ideally they're talking
600 seat grand stand
thanks chris yeah councillor cracker
thank you councillor ludlow
steal one of these my question is around
i i understand that there's been a few
community meetings
where those clubs likely affected by the
grandstand got together to have a bit of
a corridor about
what the possibilities might be um did
you
was there anything resolved in that if a
plan was delayed and
like a business case was stated that it
became
a much grander project would there be
any commitment
to um fundraising part of that not too
dissimilar to what the softball club and
queen's park have done well obviously
yeah um
and they are we've only had one meeting
um
and that was to discuss whether or not
we were putting a submission in
as a group of organizations um
because as you say you know a business
case study
and um
some people are affected more by it than
others
um so of course there's little
concern over a loss of identity for
clubs and things like that when they go
into one building
so that's all stuff that has to be
worked out
if we know that then the decision is
going to be delayed we can actually
then get together and say okay this is
what do we want
working with the council to say well
okay
here's an idea let's investigate it
let's work out what the business cases
is for it um and then have the
discussions with funders i've already
been had talks with the ilt
and community trust over
the grandstand because what's the first
thing they ask you when you go
for a meeting for something else oh
what's happening with the grandstand
so um i've already had some
informal discussions with him over that
so yeah the ball is rolling but it's a
matter of
if the council is prepared to actually
delay decision for 12 months or
so so that all that can be investigated
it may be that it's not feasible to do
anything other than what's been proposed
but now is the opportunity to actually
look at the opportunity and work
with all the parties instead of each
individual
working by themselves and then in 12
months and two years time going i wish
we'd go and
work together and come up with something
that was better
sure thank you chris thanks chris thank
you for
uh for your submission on behalf of
athletics southland and for taking the
time to come along and speak to it today
we appreciate it no worries thank you
very much
dr lipsky
welcome back uh just a reminder you've
got 10 minutes for your submission
we'll ring a bell at five minutes um and
if you can try and leave a bit of time
for counsellors to ask questions
at the end thank you curacao um dear
counselors the mayor
thank you for this opportunity um i'm
extremely excited to suggest
two major aspects for the health and
well-being or the recreational precinct
bluff although there has been one little
page in the great bluff
tourism master plan i think that has
been not done very professionally and we
have not considered
the effects that we can actually do with
such an area
if you can see this in front of you
hopefully on your screens
you look at the top the benefits of i'm
suggesting basically a health and
well-being center
at the former or still available but not
really use squash courts next to the
rugby club which
is part of the rugby club i believe that
they're not used at all in their
beautiful space that could be used for
a space to actually
support the local community and the
residents for
everything that we know about tafarita
paffa and te feke which are well-being
concepts that are very exclusive to new
zealand
yet mostly we just put up posters in our
companies
or in our you know buildings to about
that we barely do something
although we know that exercise and
strength training and all types of
fitness
a huge benefit across every single age
group
they're not only for cardiovascular
preventing cardiovascular diseases but
also
specifically something that we learned
hopefully after 2020 is mental illnesses
and exercise can prevent massively any
type of depression disorders
as well as benefit any you know progress
into dementia which are on the rise due
to an activity also due to
the fact that we're not really
approaching sports and recreation the
right way
which has been highlighted by the
futures and foresights group in various
reports and papers
for example developing alternate futures
by sport new zealand
where it has been highlighted we need a
more centralized and more singularity
approach
thus as you can see in the information
graphic i'm suggesting to work with all
the groups
in bluff and also to the benefit of the
companies as you can see in the
infographic under number four funding
and sustainability
the companies that are the workers in
bluff are working where they would have
a massive benefit
actually to their bottom line which has
been shown across the world for oil rigs
for coal mines which is very similar to
halibut heavy work
like on the port like in the dairy
company open country as well as in
rakiora
for all the salmon fishing and similar
work yet i was not able to get any
positive response from these companies
which is to be honest a bit shocking
thus i'm asking you to consider such a
project because there's nothing really
for the people
of bluff that has been actually pointed
out
even in the master plan which i find
very surprising
that as tourism has been considered
first although we've seen in 2020 how it
works if you have like a town like tiana
or everywhere across the world hundred
thousands of um
tourism towns that have been locally
focused on tourism rather than the local
residents
and that's the first part to make this
the heart of the recreational pressing
the second the second part that i'm
suggesting is because i know that has
been submissions or at least um
discussions around the swimming pool um
some of the mountain biking that we're
presenting during these days as well
to actually provide more activities and
availability of sports and recreation to
the bluff residents
is to have a big commitment
to this to have an actual long-term plan
have professionals from the health
sports exercise while being
work on this and make this area around
the rugby club the swimming club
this revamped squash courts the center
the center recreational this
recreational center in bluff
really where we have a hub for the
mountain biking where people can come
and park for their mountain biking when
there is people
who don't know where to mountain bike
because we don't have that many tracks
yet
can have um information some other
reports like identifying the drivers and
amplifications of change which clearly
show
by sport new zealand that we have to gut
away from this thinking of
isolated sports clubs that have very low
participation
and decreasing participations especially
sports that are very complicated to
teach and go more towards
for working on haura on well-being on
making singularity sports clubs where
there is more on offer than just
rugby or just cycling where we actually
give the people the opportunity to pick
and choose
together and i think this will be an
amazing case study actually for all of
new zealand to lead
like sport new zealand has suggested
with a modern approach
right here in bluff thank you thank you
dr
lipsky the first two
[Music]
costings that you've got for your
equipment cost yes and first year of
operation at
62 uh minimum and 137
optimum yes um where
which organizations do you see that
funding coming from
i think this should be community-based
fund coming from the council
just solely from no council like that
comes to the question who wants to
invest in that because
people might see just a return on
investment but the return investment is
not an investment
return it's a return on well-being so
the go i would love that the local
companies to
support that i have high doubt because i
know that
i know how much they support the local
rugby club as a joke
um so it's just the only way i can put
it
and i doubt they are interested because
i have contacted them and
tried to make these suggestions which
are not my opinion they're data-based
they're evidence-based it works across
the world
we see this across so definitely yes but
if that doesn't work i
see community funding but the accounts
of funding
there is unicorn net union co-op based
recreational centers across the whole
world world
queenstown itself runs the recreational
centers themselves for example we don't
have to go very far
so i don't see why the car like what
accounts was considering investing
was it another eight million into the
swimming pool here another 16 million in
the rugby stands
i would be unwilling to actually look at
the larger bluff precinct
that is confusing to me thank you
councillors councillor partner thank you
chair um
with uh with southport yes
um have you tried going the step higher
and
uh submitting to the regional council
who are
50 shareholders no was that something i
was not informed by that i
know yeah regional councillors yeah
satellite
environment south and they're
responsible okay they are 30
i have the helps based on the current
conversations i had
but yeah it's good to know that thank
you
thank you any other questions counselors
if not thank you for the presentation
that you've put together dr lipsky and
for coming along this morning
thank you
mr thompson thank you for your
submission and for traveling down to
speak to it we appreciate that
oh thank you and good morning mayor and
councillors
and thank you for the opportunity um
he's just listening to some of that's
most interesting and i just
like to comment that uh it is uh
certainly nice to have
a lot of things like closed streets and
people sitting out there and narrowing
up
tay street but i think why is one
person said why would you narrow a good
street when it's doing the job at the
moment
and um a lot of care needs to be done
in shutting streets new brighton and
christchurch
closed its um streets off years ago and
it killed the
thing and um rangiora
cut its down to one lane and now it's
back to two lanes
um with parking uh
the thing about it is that new
zealanders
and the provincial towns our provincial
towns are not large european cities
where
uh you find that there's a population
that's
traveling on public transport and lives
in town
and as easily able to
get around through underground trains
and all sorts of things
here invercargill's like a lot of other
provincial towns reliant on people
coming here by car from
outer districts and we want to really
bring them in from the outer districts
because
they are the ones that help support the
retail and other things that happen in
invercargill
and i just think that before people rush
into some of these things they need to
really
try and establish whether it is going to
be a good thing too
you know i'm also concerned about
don street with removing the umbrella
which was
donated by a lot of people by the bricks
you can see there
and um taking away more car parks again
it's a similar sort of situation
the invocative council has done well
over the years to keep its
debt at a low level which is commendable
unfortunately i can see in the future
that it's got some major costs coming
ahead
and i think they need to be careful
because i know it's very nice now with
interest rates the way they are at
prison but i've been through the 20
type interest rates and i'll tell you
what once they start going up
if they go up and they hit you that can
be very painful experience
um the um rates increases too
you know it's all very well uh waking
them on but
a lot of people in business particularly
they're faced with wage increases
uh compliance costs all these other
things and
it just compounds so if wage increases
are
also at a five percent a year and it's
compounding it it soon mounts up to a
lot of extra money
and i do think that the business sector
and the farming sector
need to be considered i know there are
more voters in
residences residential areas but
the business areas and things you know
you don't want to kill them off because
and same with farming it has its issues
as well that it's got to compete at the
moment
um i would um also
point out that i think the council as i
mentioned in my submission you need to
be careful when they've got a chance to
save some money
why don't they and in the case of
demolishing that building it's just left
a
gap in the streetscape now which doesn't
really do anything for a town
um the museum i i think it was my view
it should have been reassessed
to see what was the problem if it was
nothing too major
get it sorted and keep it open rather
than the cost of temporary shifting it
and disrupting things
and then take your time and look at the
long-term view and see what you're going
to do but
to me it was just a hasty decision
anderson's park i believe is a lovely
old building
and needs to be preserved
and it could be a great venue for
weddings and other
such functions and i think it needs to
have them
their money spent on it and
rugby park yes i think that's another
thing that
should be probably hopefully utilized
for other things other than rugby as
well
because um if you've got the venues
around
and when mccarthy's been very fortunate
over the years with the licensing trust
contributing a lot to a lot of the
venues like the velodrome and other
places
which have been a great addition to
sporting activities
around invercargill and um probably at
the moment they're a bit
catch-strapped with their development
but um
that they will uh no doubt in time be
able to assist with some of these other
things as well
the uh the difficulty i see coming for
the council is that
with the cbd development
there's a tremendous cost there and i
think that
until the income flow is sufficient to
cover the cost
somebody's going to have to pay for it
and i i can foresee quite a drain on the
rates
uh coming ahead for that and i think
that should be born of mine
um i think that's probably all i'd like
to say at the moment but i have to
answer any questions
thank you mr thompson council it's open
to you for questions counselor clark
yeah yeah good morning here um
you lightly touched on the museum and
said it shouldn't have been closed
and so i'll just park that up at this
stage i guess
council has three or four options to
consider going forward
whether we strengthen just to a minimum
level where we strengthen to a
higher level whether we do further work
to future proof it or whether we have a
new build i just wondered what
what your what your consideration would
be around some of those options
well i thought they're strengthening to
a minimum level and keeping it operative
and available as a museum which would be
the best thing and then
over time and when they can see what
other major commitments they've got
because if you can save a bit of money
for a while um
then you can probably use the benefits
of that to do something worthwhile
and you know we don't like even some of
the streets here like esque street was
done up a few years ago and then we're
ripping out the bits again
um why isn't enough thought put into
some of these things to do them
once and do them right and so that
they've
got a long-term benefit otherwise you
spend a lot of time just
ripping up stuff you spend a lot of
money on just not long ago
thanks for that thank you counselors any
other
questions
if not thank you for your submission mr
thompson and for coming along this
morning thank you
uh i don't think mr mcpherson is here as
yet is he
not yet we'll just take a brief
adjournment until he arrives
chance to stretch your legs
[Music]
[Laughter]
just wants to leave them
is
[Music]
there's
[Music]
so you know
oh
if you'd like to come back to the table
oh well where's councillor lush
thank you
today
thank you councillors we will be taking
a formal break after the submission
george has just got some
handouts from mr mcpherson
hi
uh
i think it's 40-46
i'll uh reconvene the hearing uh mr
mcpherson welcome along uh obviously not
your first time
uh submitting but we appreciate the fact
you've not only made a submission but
come along to speak to us this morning
the floor is yours sir
thank you mr chairman uh your honor
dixon samir and councillors
my submission this morning is on the
long term plan
that the limitation on residential lot
sizes or lot size regulation should be
abolished
now in front of you you have two
photographs or two
pictures of development
which i think should still be allowed in
the city
the property at 75 alice street
is on 605 square meters
and there are four apartments or
units there which were built back in
2010
and the other picture or photo you have
is of three units
at 43 low street invercargill
and they are on 577 square meters
now both those developments due to the
current district plan
are not permissible and i just wonder
why
i would have thought that the council
would be very keen to allow
uh the use of unused land
and there are a great number of uh
sections in invercargill between 600 and
700 square meters
which now can't be subdivided
for infill housing or an additional
unit or townhouse at the back because
of the current legislation which permits
only
a 400 square meter main site and a
subsidiary site of 350 square meters
so anything under 750 is not
subdivisible
it means that those people there are
hundreds of them who own
sections with old houses on between say
550 and 650 or 700 square meters
cannot subdivide that site
and a lot of them are the mum and dad
owners who already have a house
and they're left with perhaps an old
villa that's becoming deliberated
on a site that they can't subdivide
they can demolish the house and build
only one residence on that site
now there are sufficient i believe uh
checks and balances to not cause any
what you'd call problems with
what some people would call high density
development
to me these are not high density
they are moderate density if you look at
the
picture of the 43 low street you'll see
there there's three units
they meet all the requirements with
maneuvering
vehicle maneuvering uh distance between
living spaces
uh thanks to a very good designer i was
able to erect three
uh dwellings on that site it's only 577
square meters
and as many of you know the modern rules
are good
and that you have to provide north
facing
windows today in a north or west facing
outdoor area those are all complied with
and with the recession plan requirement
there's no worry about over shading
adjoining properties
so that's generally my submission mr
chairman
and i hope councillors will take that on
board a lot of people don't realize that
the
rules were changed back when the the
current district plan
come into being and for some reason the
council
hasn't allowed a slightly denser
development they've actually gone out to
a wider space
and these units which
at the present high quality
accommodation
for rental including some with two
bedrooms and two bathrooms
uh very much in demand and the city is
extremely short of this type of
development
thank you thank you mr mcpherson can i
can i ask with the
minimum density requirements in the
district plan
um and as a developer would you say it's
possible to
to get below those requirements if
if you're able to mitigate um
amenity concerns and and other
um you know the light spill and and
turning circles
that it is possible to get below that
with good design well i think i've
demonstrated that with the two examples
which were permissible in
2010 and 2013 i must be one of the
luckiest people in the world
to be able to do this and i thought it
was was
it was replacing extremely old
dumps you might call them uh cold
old houses with brand new modern
buildings which provided of course seven
occupations
as against two close to the city and
there's a whole raft of advantages of
having
a more dense population close to the
inner city
thank you councillor pottinger thank you
chair
brian yeah you raised a really good
point um
so would you you just mentioned close to
the city
okay would you see uh sort of a zoning
like take
windsor take south invercargill would it
make sense
to have um this intensive housing
close walking distance to those you know
shopping areas
you know or or hubs does that you know
not just
cbd but you've got the windsor is
important one south city
you've got other ones around
invercargill and
or would you just have it open slather
and this intensification is
could happen anywhere or would you like
to see more control
well i think personally i'd like to see
it available
not restrict property owners
anywhere in the city you make a very
good point
if it's close like windsor here already
has a lot of
infill housing there which were built in
the 1990s and the
2000s but can't be built now
but i can remember back in 2007
subdividing a property and the back
section was 313 square meters
and that was that was adequate because
you still only have to cover 40 percent
of the
of the of the land uh a good point
um yeah quickly developed
that these are slightly high density
areas i don't call them
high density at all i call this very
much
moderate density housing and
having it close to the the
populous shopping centers is also is a
good idea but
i'd like to see it expanded i have no
personal
um grudge here
i won't be buying these sections if you
do approve
of this it's not a personal grudge
it's just a concern i'll have for the
future of the city for your long-term
plan
to enable more concentrated
new building occurring in a lot of areas
where the land
is uh superfluous or it's gone to waste
um to me anything over 600 square meters
should be able to be subdivided and
infill housing built or
um townhouses or whatever thank you
councillor clark
yes thank you chair um brian you touched
on the issue of rental demand
which we know we have which is the
supply and demand of housing in the city
and it's right across southern
so we have a real shortfall there but
the other issue i'd like to
pick your brains on i guess is where
there is a demand for
people who want to retire and downsize
so these small clusters are actually
a bit smaller than maybe um going to a
retirement village but as my
colleague just mentioned it could be
close to queen's park it could be close
to shopping centres
where they can walk or not be reliant on
being too far out
i just wonder whether you're picking up
any demand from people that might want
to take a large family house
downsize into something smaller and more
manageable and release equity for their
retirement
and that helps with the supply demand as
well that's a very good point
fortunately i was able to
consult with surveyors and have these
individual
units in low street separate titled
so they can be sold for the likes of
retired people
the occupation of these um flats take
the
low street ones uh are only one and two
people
it's not big crowds that some people
might fear in a more
moderate classification of density
thank you thank you
okay councillors thank you very much mr
mcpherson for your submission and for
taking the time to come along this
morning
councillors that brings us to our first
formal break um
so i will uh adjourn the hearings
for 10 minutes we reconvene at 20 to
11.
like to take a seat welcome along
just before you start a reminder to
those uh presenters that have just
arrived along uh you have ten minutes um
to speak we will ring a bell at five
minutes and another one at ten
um if if you'd like to leave the
opportunity for
counsellors to ask questions if you
don't use the full ten minutes
thanks hugh yeah good morning council
and i'm here and my staff um
good to be here again today um just
before i started give a shout out to um
the team that worked on this ltp
um alex particularly the project
champion um probably one of the best
pieces of documentation i've had to read
from the council before um very well
presented
easy to understand i think it's spoken
to and the numbers you've had in
submissions
to that so congratulations and keep that
up um just a couple of points i wanted
to make firstly was just picking up on
the previous speaker's commentary around
housing
um some of you might know we provide
products into the housing market so i
get to see
housing across this nation um in
auckland and tauranga and wellington and
places like that where we're seeing
significant growth
um i in principle agree with mr
mcpherson's suggestion of high
identification i also
um part of me disagrees i think invicals
one of the few cities like christchurch
that has the ability to grow
it's borders easily we have no
geographic geographical geography
restraints or topography constraints as
cities like wellington oakland tauranga
do
with um inlets and um
and the general allow the land so i
think invercargill has got an
opportunity to grow significantly if
um council is prepared to expand the
borders we're not a big city we've got a
good roading system
if you look around the city all corners
of the city are serviced by good good
roadways
i understand there is restrictions on
infrastructure having just recently
built in the northwest
which i think should be addressed sooner
rather than later i particularly believe
that the
area north of queen's drive should be
explored rapidly for um
housing as many would know stage two of
invera is now sold
stage three is going to market soon
nearly the dust class sections of
northwood and near seoul which is the
last sections that are available in the
northwest of the city
so i think that should be explored
quickly um i think it should be done as
a
council and private partnership
obviously it's a big risk for council to
do something like that
but i believe they have the land and
should move on it quickly i think with
more land we can provide
our residents the more housing we built
the more jobs we'll create for our
future generations
the real point i wanted to cover off
today was um congratulations on the ltp
overall i think it's a really gutsy one
i think it's great to see the councils
leveraging their balance sheet to to
to transform the city i think the
roadmap to renewal is a brilliant title
um there's kind of this it's not it's
not it's not an understatement to say
that um
the city is going through transformation
as i say i travel a lot and see a lot of
cities and
um and the cargo's going to move i think
into probably one of the best
cbds of a medium-sized city in the
country um i was just entering cbd last
week and i was
disgusted a city that's well known for
its um the city cbd of tauranga
has been destroyed by the large malls
that have been built on the east and
west sides of the city so i think it's
fantastic that our city's going to have
a more smack in the middle um for our
children and our grandchildren
so congratulations council on that my
bigger point i wanted to make was um
really around the fact that um we need
to change the national narrative around
our city
um it hasn't been helped by the fact
that um our cbd has been the front door
and a fairly obvious chatty one at that
um that is changing
and i think it's time for us to own that
um
change the narrative um if you're in
business you're selling a product
ah you've got to have the product to
sell and then b you've got to market the
heck out of it
people don't know about it until you
tell them and i think that's where we
stop today
particularly going into next year i
think the council should lead a
um a business council partnership around
marketing
um we're trying to recruit um high level
staff to our head office here in novel
and it's a challenge but i know if we
had a collaborative
effort from business along with council
promoting
the city as a great place to live
obviously the cbd is going to be a
tangible transformation
i believe that count businesses would be
happily to contribute some of their
marketing spend to that
um i think there's a enormous community
um demonstrated by the involvement of
hwr
which is the obvious ones um others paul
adams and others that are
actively support southland and are based
here because they love the city
and ourselves included so i'd like to
see some movement on that and have you
discuss it with councillors now or
offline
um so yeah with that i'd just like to
say thank you for um taking initiative
for
for um the city and great work on the
ldp and i hope it moves forward quickly
thank you and thank you for the the kind
feedback as well counsellors it's open
for questions councillor lush and then
councillor partner yeah thanks so much
for your positivity what do you see with
when recruit
you for recruiting work is what do you
see is there resistance to moving down
here
and is it borne out in fact i think i
think of you marcus as an example um
someone that's proudly lives in bluff
and
has obviously come from the big smoke my
twin brother lives in auckland and i
can't understand why he does
um and i can understand why you live in
bluff i think it's a perception
i was talking to a business owner last
week at a conference and he asked me
where was based and he said are you
based in auckland
and i said i'm based in vergara to the
offices he looked like it's what a lemon
people simply don't understand what's
here it's a perception that's been
driven by
in part media apologies and look it's
one of those things we have to overcome
but i also think given that we're
starting from behind
if you might say we're the underdog that
in turn and this current age i believe
is an upside because
we have the ability to actually change
that narrative and i think southerners
too are also very conservative when it
comes to promotion
so i think having something to talk
about i think the rebrand the council
did three years ago
albeit fairly hidden at the moment it
was brilliant like the logos and
everything i mean it's all part of the
story
i don't answer the question
thank you chair huge um are you aware
that later on this afternoon
we have the ppp committee meeting
discussing
the new national policy statement on
urban development are you
aware of that new national policy
statement not specifically
now it would be great to just have a
read of the agenda for this afternoon
and
um yeah i was just wondering if you did
because it touches on
a lot of the comments about urban
development and freeing up land sure
that's on the council website is it
uh it'll be in there yes it is yeah for
this afternoon
further questions
if not uh thank you again for your
submission and uh the positive feedback
which is
which is appreciated thanks thank you
jeanette
welcome along
yes you can sorry dakota my name is
jeanette
um firstly i would like to say that my
grandparents are from here
my grandfather was the foreman of the
train station at a time when
our resources were shared by everyone
i'd also like to point out the coat of
arms on the wall right there that
translates to
for the benefit of the people so i come
with the bluff living wage group and
we would like to see the long-term plan
benefit all people
but especially we ask you to consider
those on lower incomes
bluff living wage speaks for those who
often don't have a voice when it comes
to the
long term plan what is built where it is
built
and how it is built and also who
benefits from
it is really important to us we see
the implications of a really high income
gap
in new zealand and we notice that it's
been
the largest and the fastest growing
income gap in the oecd
so we're speaking to that um yeah so
that inequity is something that we
actively move to close that gap and we
do that by
upholding the living wage and the living
wage is it's only a little bit above the
minimum wage at the moment but still
it's a significant amount
that means that people can actively
participate in their communities
more freely so we would like to see
some governance on this issue and some
leadership from our council
to implement the living wage um and
their long-term plan and strategies
especially for the
the likes of any procurement contractors
people that
you're employing um within the
organization and
um how that is contracted out we see the
benefits of this
for the community is like tenfold um
we'd like to also uh point out that
there's numerous other city councils
that
do implement the living wage in their um
governance um the dunedin city council
for instance and they've found that in
doing so
the immediate cdb business
communities have benefited from doing
that so they see the revenue just going
back into a community
um yeah so the living wage movement is
closing the gap
and it's benefiting the economy um
we're asking for you to make the living
wage a priority
in your long-term budget and i think
that's
all i have to say for now does anyone
have questions next jeanette
um the living wage
what's the gap between that and the new
adult minimum wage
so it's at the moment it's 2.10
and in september that will go up to 2.75
per hour so it's not a significant
amount
and in fact i think we calculate that
there's
almost about a quarter of the employees
at the city council
are receiving at the minimum wage and we
see that by increasing
two dollars ten per hour would only be
in the realms of about two hundred
thousand dollars per year
it's not a lot but it does have
significant benefits to the community
especially like things when what we see
people having um less stress when they
have more income
that more easily contribute to society
um
yeah just mental health issues things
like that there are all impacted
by lower incomes and increasing the
income has
massive implications for health or um
society at large so yes thank you
councillor pottinger um thank you chair
um
you've read the uh roadmap too and you
have
yeah right just i'd like to your comment
on
council's proposed rating change
for the low residential values and and
when you read the commentary
it it it is looking for those people on
lower incomes
so i just wondered what your comment was
about council
you know striving to to actually do
something proactive there
um i think my general comment is that
it's um like proportionally like this
invicable city council
um tax increases are i think of of
benefit and timely
as well in comparison to other um areas
where the taxes
have have been a lot higher um
yeah i could you speak to anything
absolutely yeah no um you know what
you're doing is great however
um
oh yeah no i'm just talking about the
rates for the
all of them yeah all of them cope with
no that's that's fine
thanks thank you further questions
counselors
counselor rabbit just a quick one i i
mismissed
your comment on the minimum or living
wage as applicable to
our workforce what did you say with a on
the minimum or
the living so yeah we note that almost a
quarter of the workforce is on the
minimum wage
thank you further questions
if not you survived well done thank you
very much for your submission and coming
along this morning
lindsay
let me have a moment um
i am concerned about
how the money is being spent
and how it has been spent in the past
and how budgets
seem to be blowing out all the time and
we now have this huge mall that we're
going to have
and um we keep
the council keeps asking rate payers to
pay more money and now
you know our pockets are only so deep
so as much as i agree with the mall
and i'd love to see some great parks
around
the um esque street and easter egg
closed off the bikes and that sort of
thing there are other things that
may need to be considered and
i'm just not 100 sure given the
history of what has been done in the
past
whether we won't end up with a huge
blowout again that the ratepayers are
going to have to pay
we've had the swimming pool which in
years got in the first years
was supposed to be what it is now and i
think i see we didn't really need
at that time to do a world tour to find
paul we only had to go two hours at the
road to moana pool
we now have the iteration four
iterations later and so i've been told
there's going to be a new one
so all those things have also cost
money that didn't really need to be if
it being done correctly the first time
the inner city um office space
that for whatever reason was built and
can't be rented out is obviously
another concern for budgets and
ratepayers are paying for that
rural land forestry it all seems
that whatever this council or
councils before have been involved in
to better the city and it's been done in
in many ways
kind of okay i've been i hear
backwards and forwards many times so i
come back here because now i have
grandchildren here
um parking is easy to go to the shops
and things like that
and obviously parking will be easier
once we have the small although i'm sure
with online shopping i'm not sure who's
going to really be buying there
um you know the queen's park we could
have had a nice
margaret mayhe type park years ago and
years ago i have said the same thing
we're in southland we need areas that
are sheltered for our children to play
in
the museum was good we could walk around
the museum at different
even with my own children now my
grandchildren but we don't have that
and that's going to obviously cost a lot
of money to be back to where it was
a few years ago we could incorporate a
great science museum if we go two hours
up the road and look at dunedin's
science museum and observatory
and still look at the winer pool because
it's still there
although i was told 20 odd years ago
that it was leaking and it would be
pulled down
so i think in a way as
much as i like
the city and being here because it's
convenient it's 10 minutes
across towns you have like other huge
cities
we still need to you guys and your
accountants and those that tell you
these portfolios are obviously
hemorrhage money
need to perhaps reconsider how
you finance things or how the finance is
going to work
so that our rates aren't increasing
because our
future children and grandchildren never
going to be able to afford to own a home
or even pay the rates for a home
which brings me to another point with
rates that i think
it should be more
fear to not just hike the rates up on
people's properties who
actually take care of their property but
also the properties and more so the
properties that aren't
in good repair because they're the ones
that end up costing the rate payers more
money in demolitions or
services or anything like that and you
know the long grass and the
shabby windows or whatever they still
use the same services they still use the
water the serious toilets and all that
sort of thing
but they have less rates to pay
than someone who has taken care of the
property or even
built and added to the property to
enhance it
which brings me along to another thing
is the
building and department here
just seemed to um
i suppose lauded over everyone with
their interpretation of the building
code it is an interpretation
i'm heavily involved in that area and
i've
gathered lots of information throughout
the country on
fees and charges and what has
been charged here that has put people
off building here and living here in the
commercial buildings being built here
so as much as all these people would
like to see a great city and
congratulate you on having this fine
city
sometimes the what's the word i'm
looking for
unconscious unconscious innateness
is or consciousness actually it's a
strangling
city with your own red tape i know of
many designers and builders
uh architects that are struggling
to talk with your building inspectors
and get them on board with
the actual interpretation of the code
and it is frustrating there are so many
people that have decided not to live
invercargill
because of those reasons um
and pretty much that's it i mean it's a
good city to move around
and oh and narrowing apparently
narrowing the streets again
we used to have centre parking before
and that was all removed because it
wasn't viable so
we're going to be narrowing the streets
against history going to repeat we're
going to end up paying more money for
stuff that will be pulled down in 10
years time in the long term plan
railways how many railway crossings
have been resealed and resealed and
you'd see
resealed through costs that go to the
ratepayer in the end
but you know the concrete blocks over
every crossing
would be perfect because they don't need
any more maintenance
we've just had you know where the
roundabout is
on bluff road alice road
that area there it was only through
lockdown that that
top of alice road there was sealed at
great cost
and now it's all been ripped up again in
the long term plan
so how long is the long-term plan
and do you not feel that perhaps the
rate payers are entitled to have
perhaps more say or um
more lenience on some of the accounts
that are apparently
available to council that can be
directed
to offset certain finances
instead of waiting for the rainy day
that may never come
or maybe this is going to be the rainy
day when that all is finished
anyway that's all i have to say
excellency council is open for questions
councillor pottinger thank you chair um
lindsay just looking at your
comments here and writing on the city
centre
um have you if you actually had a good
look at the
plan that we're um that's coming up for
adoption this afternoon
if you looked at the streetscapes i did
a wee while ago and then i was told oh
it's going to be changing so i thought
oh well i'll just wait till it's
actually going ahead okay just sit it i
i
noticed your comment about the height of
things you know um not being
uh yeah not having too high things to
trip on and stuff
and i just wondered so i think it would
be great to read that
so i just wanted to be ready i did ask
um
i was one of council i was a building
inspector
because i did trip over at one of the
shops on just a small bit of bitumen
that had been left
because i can't um lift my foot
or maybe two three mil so it's a lot of
scraping
and my foot hit a ramp that had been
repaired so that people do not trip on
it
and i tripped right over it so when i
was talking to the building inspector i
can't remember who it was
um i asked if the mall was going to be
um i suppose wheelchair friendly user
friendly
and he said yes it would be for
wheelchairs and i said well that's
not enough because wheelchairs can roll
over stuff
but people that have had strokes and i'm
in a big group of people that have
strokes
they can't lift their foot or their leg
so they skim and
as well their muscles are a lot weaker
than they used to be so
opening doors you know if the mall had
sliding doors or electric doors and
moving doors
instead of doors you have to push is
absolutely
you just i can't describe the strength
needed just to open it
my question thanks for that and my
question again was just about
how you obviously haven't seen the
latest one so you've come no i haven't
seen the latest one yeah and uh
regarding those
respect to three weeks ago thank you
thank you any further questions
counselors
if not thank you lindsey for your
submission and for taking the time to
speak to it
thank you all public health
south jameson lynn
welcome along to this unfamiliar process
to you both
thank you for your warm welcome mr tear
my name is janice burton
and with my colleague lynn grace we are
both health promoters in our public
health cell
invercargill office public health south
is the main source
of expert public health advice within
southern dhb currently
during our covert response public health
still wants to maximize eric's support
for community well-being
now that the gut local government act
incorporates again the four well-beings
we see real synergies between our
organizations
the invercargill city council has an
important role in shaping our community
for the well-being of our residents
health begins where we live learn
work and play new zealand research has
shown that the strongest
influence for people's health comes from
factors
outside the health sector they
include social cultural physical and
economic environments in which
people live public health units across
the country
are increasingly using the united
nations sustainable development goals
when working with councils particularly
around well-being
in 2015 the united nations general
assembly
adopted a set of 17 goals
to end prosperity to protect
the planet and to ensure prosperity for
all
as part of a sustainable holistic
development agenda
each goal has specific targets and for
those countries which have adopted them
including new zealand
these targets are expected to be reached
over 15 years
so that health can be improved for all
today we will focus on the center city
master plan
and the urban play space and in relation
to this
three of the sustainable development
goals are particularly
relevant number three
is to ensure healthy lives and promote
well-being
for all at all ages
number eleven is fostering healthier
cities
through urban planning for cleaner air
and safer and more active living
and number 17 is mobilizing partners
to attain the social development goals
and
improve health for all
dr lucy saunders is a public health
specialist
and transport planner who contributed to
the london transport
strategy she developed
the healthy street indicators which is
an evidence-based approach
for fairer sustainable and attractive
spaces
which consider the health impacts of
transport
public health and urban planning
the indicators are ten key elements
that are considered necessary for public
spaces
streets and parks to improve people's
health
while making urban places socially
and economically vibrant
one indicator is that people choose
active transport to walk and
to cycle pedestrians will do
that when it is easy to cross a street
so that people of all ages and all
abilities
feel safe cities which
prioritize cycling effectively
often have similar numbers of women and
men cycling i think we have a little bit
of work to do on that
locally i think we see more men than
women cycling
with increased active transport the
streetscape is less
noisy and the air is cleaner
where there are things to see and do
places to stop and dress and good shade
and shelter
are provided people feel relaxed
and welcome they will be drawn to such
spaces
and will spend time there
we recommend that public toilets and a
breastfeeding facility
is included in the plan so that that
means
it meets the needs of all ages including
young families
creating such environments enhances the
physical mental and spiritual well-being
and encourages social connection
i'll take it from here thanks janice
i'll just like to give you a little bit
of context of where i fit in
public health and my role is liquor
licensing
which is a um a role that
i deal with the licensed premises in
town and we sign off
along with the police and the
inspectors um it is also a health
promotion role
and that role is looking at the the
well-being and alcohol
alcohol harm reduction in our
communities
um so firstly i'd like to take the
opportunity to commend the council's
proactive and collaborative approach
around developing and maintaining the
local alcohol policy
and also the ongoing implementation of
liquor ban and then the cargo cbd
these harm reduction actions they align
with the sale and supply of alcohol act
and by maintaining our community's
amenity in good order
it also supports the purpose and the
object of the act
icc's alcohol harm reduction actions
also align with the sustainable
development goal
to ensure healthy lives and promote
wellbeing for all at all ages
in relation to the liquor ban we asked
the council
that they would consider extending this
liquor band area to encompass the south
city
as a high deprivation area
we ask the council provide and maintain
distinguishable but tasteful signage and
that is obvious to the public
that they are either entering or are in
a likaben area as well
reducing exposure of alcohol consumption
and promotion
in public settings supports the amenity
in good order
and healthy community behaviours
in relation to the proposed inner city
play space
health recommend in their submission
that any
family or social space that is developed
uh we trust that council would consider
reducing exposure to the consumption of
alcohol
we ask that these spaces are not
subjected to outdoor dining
and seating where alcohol consumption
in smoking is prominent prominent or
likely to occur
an easy example of what we don't want to
see in the public space
and particularly in front of young
people is having to walk through
smokers and drinkers such as they do on
the way to the library or to
walk in place outside front of
spates ale house if an urban play or
outdoor
space is considered we recommend council
take the opportunity to explore the
possibility of access
to the space in an area for vendors
arts opportunity for events such as
buskers festivals
which create the vibrance in the city
health would suggest the community space
is restricted from pop-up bars portable
bars
and so forth once again lowering
exposure to alcohol
in some supporting amenity in good order
we thank you for your attention and
forward thinking into areas
which this support which support
sustainable development goals in
preparation are for generations to come
thank you janice and lennon thank you
for the detail on the various uh points
and uh um consultation documents that
your feedback on in in your written
submission
lynn if i can just ask around your
suggestion
of uh liquor ban area in south city has
that followed
an approach from from
any organizations anyone or
increase in incidents um i'm not aware
of inclusive
incidents but it does i guess it's
it is an area that has become has been
looked at with
self alive and has become quite a
um we hub it is changing i can't say
that it's developing
but it does align it is
often the south area where we central
hub
and it does align i think with the
principles of the cbd
where it's it's a hub there as well it's
just something to consider there are
a lot of food outlets um up that area
um so it is a gathering point
so if i can expand on that then is it
something that council should look at in
areas other areas where there are hubs
as well possibly
um it would be with consultation i
i would imagine with police to to
identify
issues um is there issues in windsor is
there issues in south
um it would be through that consultation
whether they
whether you move forward on a liquor ban
in that area
that's principal purpose of a lick ban
is to to reduce the harm
thanks lynn councillors
if not thank you very much for a very
detailed submission and for the
additional commentary you've provided
this morning we appreciate it
yvonne yvonne mcclellan
good timing well done
welcome along yvonne if you can just
make sure that you um have that
microphone in front of you
you've got 10 minutes we'll give you a
ballot five um
if if you want to take questions from
counsellors just make sure you leave a
bit of room before we get to ten
um i'm not used to speaking in this
kind of situation but i thought that my
um
submission that i made was pretty
straightforward for those of you who
read it
and my my main objection was to spend
52 million dollars to refurbish a
building that's only going to be 67
usable well 60 up so how much is it
going to cost us
in the years to come to bring it up to
100
you can save 52 to give us 67 it's like
with any old buildings once you start
ripping into it
what's in the contingency fund
and my idea was that you just knock it
down
and build us a whole brand new building
that's going to last us for years and
years and years to come
so has anybody got any questions to ask
me on
so thanks yvonne thanks for taking the
opportunity to come along to the odatara
consultation meeting where we had a
discussion as well so councillors it's
open
for questions if you have any of your
from
councillor amundsen and then councillor
scout
thanks evan i just wondered whether you
felt strongly uh
about whether the museum should be
rebuilt where it is or whether we could
look
at other places to put it no i've put it
here that
you put it in the same place it's
queen's park
we already own the land you don't have
to purchase any land to go anywhere else
and my other
suggestion was that you incorporate the
arts center with it
it doesn't have to be in the i mean they
can still be two separate buildings
one on one side one on the other but
joint in the middle
as a foyer that has our eye
center in it our cafeteria in it
our offices if need be the gift shops
and you're saving you're only using one
set of
facility well one set of utilities for
heating
and everything else you don't have to
provide for two different places
we have the room at queen's park
i mean it doesn't have to be an
extravagant design it just has to be a
simple design
that is going to last us for years and
years to come
thank you councillor skelt i thank you
yvonne's answer my question thank you
councillor sopa then councillor clark
thanks mr chair evons actually answered
my question as well
yeah councillor and councillor passenger
yeah yvonne uh thank you um just one
question
you made the reflection that we own the
land in queens park so
given that it's been closed for about
three years
um and people have got a little bit used
to not having it there
um and given that you suggest that we
shouldn't have to buy land
what would your view be if we had um a
museum and say lower s street where we
were looking to put the uh the uh art
gallery anyway
i fully object to it okay you you need
to put in a place where it's
accessible putting it in lower e street
is not accessible for tourists
i mean when i worked in a business i had
forever had people coming in which way
do we go to the catlins
nothing was sign marked to go anywhere
in this town
and you know you need to put something
queen's park
everyone knows where it is they know how
to get there it's easy for visitors to
get there
from even from the cbd down
and i mean you can say if we're our muse
where we've got our museum at the moment
on the corner of don street
and um calvin street i have seen
the children coming there to go and
visit there's no parking for the buses
they have to drop them off
down the road and that and i understand
that the businesses want their parking
but
you can't have it both ways you can't
have people wanting to come in there and
use it
and excluding other people to having
access okay
thank you councillor pottinger thank you
chair yvonne um
right with the with the current proposal
it's 52 million dollars
and of that 52 million 12 million
is is being relied on from external
funders
now if you built new of course we'd be
looking
for external funding as well which is
smart
do you think council would stand more
chance of getting external
funding with a beautiful inspirational
new museum
compared to a door upper certainly
i mean look at look at our mall that we
have in town
the council committed to that and
because of
one things and others we had someone
pull out which the council had to
recommit
extra funds i mean that's fine
a museum is a museum i have lived in
this
town and i have been here most of my
adult life and i'm coming 62
and i've seen a lot of projects that the
council have done over the years
that have not measured up to
are no good now a swimming pool is one
of them we were building this
state-of-the-art swimming pool with the
olympic pole you know we could have all
these events there
the failure there was they didn't
provide enough seating for spectators
we have a beautiful velodrome
that we can't really hold national
events because once again we do not have
enough seating
the only thing we've actually done built
for purpose
is our stadium which we can at least
hold international games in
right so just getting back to that
original question was
funding getting trying to attract
external funders
for a do a wrapper or something brand
new that
that was a showcase for 50 years i'd say
you'd more likely get ex more external
funding for something that is brand new
than a fixer-upper that
could require more input later on no
thank you
thank you any further questions
if not yvonne you've survived it all
well done submission and you're still
here
thank you very much for taking the time
and for coming very much for listening
anna welcome along
now that you have our attention yeah
yeah if i could have all of your
attention please no
um so i am new to southland but i
just thought i'd give you a bit of my
background and kind of a bit of context
so i hold a bachelor of science in
environmental science and physical
geography
i worked for a year and a half on a
major construction project in auckland
the city rail link project which you've
all probably heard of
um mostly in the environmental sort of
carbon accounting
side of that infrastructure project i've
done some freelance work for the spread
of adventure
on an environmental assessment for their
um works
i also hold a skipper's restricted
limits which i gained on stuart island
um and what brought me to southland was
i definitely recognised that there was
some cool stuff going on here
and some forward thinking and friendly
people
and a really beautiful rugged
environment so um
yeah most of um the requests or
kind of comments and my submission
relate to
kind of environmental sort of focused
things but also
um the way that the environment is
changing at the moment
is a really important consideration for
long-term planning
um basically we we know that the things
that have
already happened in terms of the climate
change
or the carbon dioxide we've put into the
atmosphere already
won't the the full effects won't be felt
for at least another 100 years so that's
definitely a long-term planning
sort of thing and it's not just so much
about planning to
do the right thing it's also that if the
climate changes you have to really
prudently plan
for that and i'm sure you're all very
well aware of that so
i'm sure you're all very well aware of
the national directive on
decarbonisation at the moment with the
first budget going into place
for new zealand in 2022 with the aim to
get to
completely net zero emissions by 2050
for the country
um yeah therefore just any planning or
any infrastructure project
that is implemented should definitely in
my view
be aligned and account for those
initiatives so that you don't run into
roadblocks in the future we're like oh
no we didn't take that into account or
you know we haven't looked at the carbon
footprint of this
and that then becomes kind of a
regulatory requirement later on
um but also because it is the um
sensible and just thing to do for
everyone else who lives in our region
and in our world i suppose
so yeah the physical effects being felt
as a result of climate change man-made
climate change
are forcing us to be more savvy and
efficient with the resources
um i've just been speaking recently with
someone about
electricity prices and because lake
levels are low electricity prices might
be going up or be uncertain
and it's kind of nature's own way of
forcing us to
put in solar panels because if the
electricity price goes up because we've
caused the climate to change so that it
doesn't rain you can't generate power
it's kind of
like it's forcing you to be more
efficient with
the resources you have and also
of course if you're more efficient it's
more cost effective as well
so um yeah as that becomes more
uncertain
and poses significantly greater costs i
think that when you're
in the planning stages just very prudent
to um
make sure that anything you design is
designed to
run with maximum efficiency and kind of
like minimum operating costs that was a
big thing
with the downer eska project um or the
city railing project
in auckland in that um they had kind of
milestones and things they had to
achieve for the design phase of the
project
and the operational phase so they had
certain targets to meet in terms of
water use
electricity use and all that sort of
thing which is not just a good thing for
the environment it's good for the wallet
as well
um it's also forcing us to become more
resilient i came to
which i as a definition to me
is the ability of a system to recover
after a shock
which is strongly often explained by
the modularity of the system which means
the
the big system has lots of little
components which can function
independently
and be self-sufficient so when i came
along to the evening
on the long-term plan a little while ago
there was some discussion about
water tanks which is like a perfect
example of that
where if you have a shock to the system
and maybe the main
infrastructure lines are damaged you're
actually a lot better able to
respond to that shock if you all got
little
resilient pockets of resources or
supplies of resources um so
yeah i made a recommendation that i
think it'd be great to see more sort of
planning
in that vein to look at
incorporating maybe into building
consents that people have
more modular resilient sort of
water supplies as well as i know you're
investigating
a secondary water supply for the which
is of course very prudent
like as you say with pollution and
drought um to have alternative options
but maybe we should be looking at
alternative options that are not just
similar to the one we already have but
maybe more modular which will actually
improve resilience and i just
um yeah basically like to say as an
end that it's a global problem that can
only be solved by many small actions so
every action invercargill southland's
actions even though
on the world scale seems small it's
definitely still very important
thank you thanks anna um a question
around
green design and green engineering
generally the bottom line is a little
higher um what's
your position on the long term economic
effect even though the the build cost is
higher
i definitely also um kind of throughout
my submission
mentioned that in terms of financial
planning i i believe in
higher up front costs for a lower
operating cost or a
um which will in turn have savings over
the long run
so yeah that's definitely my position on
that thanks anna
councillors councillor partner hi anna
um just regarding uh is council doing
enough
with respect to carbon sequest station
um i mean would it make a difference if
we we had empty spaces instead of being
grass
that it was actually trees which uh have
a far higher
you know sequestration i definitely
think there's potential to look at that
i think
any person who has the privilege of
owning land has an opportunity to
sequester carbon but it's um that's
one one part of the solution but it's
often referred to as a band-aid
on this yeah yeah we'll say getting away
from the financial side
yeah the actual proactive side of uh you
know yes
is in terms it's a band-aid to the
solution because it's you're still
actually putting the things out there
that are causing you to need to plant
trees so they're kind of
just like the the number one approach is
to
use less and use renewable resources in
the first place that don't create the
emissions then you don't have to
plant trees but the trees are good too
and they're probably at the moment i
think
one of our best technologies to
kind of mitigate our effects at the
moment
do worship yes
i had a campaign of
putting water tanks on every house
because of the christchurch
situation there
seemed to be quite a bit of resistance
here why do you think there was
i can't imagine i think i spoke about it
when i was here
at the other evening and in terms of i
come from one of the other farflung
regional provinces of new zealand
northland where it's very dry a lot
drier than southland and my father is
actually in the business of making water
tanks
and so there it seems very normal that
every house just has one or two and
that's just the way things are so i
can't imagine why but i suppose again
extra cost i'm not sure
councillor robinson thanks for your
presentation and aaron for all of the
great ideas that are in your
um your submission
from a counsellor point of view um the
whole
climate change thing can be quite
overwhelming to be thinking about it in
terms of
you know a whole city and what do we
need to do and where do we start
so i wondered if you had any suggestions
about what
we as councillors could ask for or
initiate with the staff is kind of a
first step to get on the journey
of really addressing issues around
climate change and acknowledging them
properly
that's a big question
so mostly by that do you mean tackling
the emissions that invercargill as a
city produces
uh yes and i guess the
city council in terms of um mitigation
and adaptation and
all of those things yeah um
i think um kind of the the basic formula
for any kind of emissions reduction
or a lot of other things as well as to
first of all
you know take quite a strategic approach
and be like you know where did where did
the majority of them come from that we
have control over and
you know what's the most cost-effective
way that we can make the biggest change
which is often called you know your
marginal abatement
analysis um and
yeah um but predominantly
the biggest things we can really affect
are fossil fuels and transport
is a huge one um i think anything that
invocable city council can do on cycling
and encouraging
cycling and invercargill would be
awesome it's just it's a very flat city
i bike myself i think it's awesome
um and that's a huge win-win-win for the
environment for people's health
less cars on the road and
also i think in terms of the wastewater
treatment plant that you have
you're currently burning off the methane
but there could be the potential to
utilize all of our waste
streams for energy i think we should
waste less
thank you councillors any further
questions
if not thanks anna for for a very
thoughtful submission and for taking the
time to come along this morning we
appreciate it thank you
mr kite timely arrival sir
welcome along
thank you worship and councillors
um do i take it as uh as read the
submission
yes yeah thanks so yeah i've just uh
i'm here to speak on behalf of the new
reversal forum
uh regarding the submission to cancel on
looking at putting in the long term plan
the invercargill the old invercargill
city
refuse dump and looking what can be done
there to
mitigate um the
issues that are there from historically
um that have been left there so
the dump was sealed in 2004
um but it actually wasn't sealed it was
a heavy
rubble seal around that and then the
dump continues to leach
into the estuary um the new reversal
forum
is a group that was started in uh 2018
of concerned people um
communities around recreational users
and other interested parties looking at
what can be done
with the new river estuary i myself i i
lead
thriving south and which is involved
with the catchment groups throughout
southland
so looking from a rural perspective
there's a focus on managing sediment and
nutrient input into the estuary
but when you look internally probably
the rubbish
the old landfill is probably an area
that needs
continues to leach into the estuary and
from a recreational viewpoint and and
from a
invercargill viewpoint um if you
actually go and
stand there and look over the estuary um
that's where people
used to collect kai they used to
under and they still do enjoy the
boardwalk down there
and and they enjoy that looking out on
the estuary but the industry obviously
needs a lot of improvement
one of our first meetings we met with
porirua
a member of the porirua council who
looked at their history and their view
was um
they'd all turned their backs on the
history so everything
within poriru faced away
because they didn't want that it became
and it became the refuse
space for the city and that's obviously
what in the past happened and
invercargill
the view the new river forum is to
we actually need to turn and look
towards the austria as an amenity um
it is a we're talking about a a a
historical issue
with the um with the dump itself but if
we can keep
kicking the can down the road um it'll
it'll never uh
get addressed so we we feel if you could
look towards putting that within your
plan
um you're looking at the stead straight
um
stock banks we're looking at uh and
sealing
along there it will be quite um i
suppose prudent to actually look at
the old refuse dump
and actually look at and say you know
it's look at the possibilities around
sealing that
um for a future um looking into the
future and from
from and when you look at i suppose
coming into vicargo into the airport
um heading down to bluff the tara trail
that that goes straight through that
area um the new arrestory forum has been
talking with
stakeholders around uh what could be
done
um but it's it's really an area where it
should be beautified and not um
left to be to be leaching and say it's
probably something that needs to
uh we need to make a start um as far as
the
forum go it's we're a no we so don't
point the blame at anybody it's about
working together as a community to
to make a difference and to make a
change that's uh we understand there
might be
you know the funding required may be
considerable
but actually looking at different
avenues and having the support of the
community
would be a way that we suggest that we
move forward thanks
thank you for that council let's just
open for questions councillor clark
yes thank you um yeah richard um i've
had some involvement with liz craig over
this i just wanted to clear that
so i'd like your view on a couple of
issues um have you done any costings of
what it would cost to sort of
duplicate the stop street uh the stop
bank work
no we haven't we're not a funded
organization either so that's
a real challenge for ourselves okay
and and over and above putting a bank in
which might stop some of the leeching
what are your views on on treat planting
as well because that can help help
mitigate as well
and that's part of the discussion to if
if um
we've been looking at beautification and
maybe linking it up
into the the work that's gone on in
bluff right the way through to the
airport
um but the issue is if uh that leaching
continues and at some point needs to be
remediated and
all so you can beautify the place but
for remediation kind of needs to happen
before you
or you need to know where that's going
to happen and at what point
uh before you can actually carry on and
beautify so there's a lot of interest in
planting
that area and and making it an area as a
side that we can actually look at on our
estuary
from but um the unders the the
investigations probably need to be done
to see what um
remediation could be done and just one
quick question
when you talk about the damages from the
leeching are you talking about
all the way around the old dub or is it
more predominant into the lagoon
we we've uh predominantly focused on the
dump but that runs out into
into the estuary you can see the lake
chat there when you walk down a walk
down on a wet day and you can
see it coming out and fly and i do know
there's got the same issues at
stead street along those stock banks but
yeah so that's
yeah thank you councillor lush then
councillor kit
yeah thanks for that um
is it possible to remove all the stuff
or that's the the stuff that's done
that's the it's there
well it's as
20 30 years of um refuse there to
so i think to remove it would be a
challenge but that's i suppose that's
one of the
areas of investigation that needs to be
looked at but yeah
but with with water rising everything it
will become
the situation will become worse with
storms and stuff releasing stuff into
history and it yes certainly well with
uh
with sea level rise if it isn't sealed
but it's probably a
an issue that a lot of cancers have um
and
and a lot of councils are looking to
deal with and
i would suggest being first cab off the
rank might be a good position
uh to be uh when you're looking at
change to remove it
oh to remediate it in whatever in
whatever way yes
counselor yeah thank you richard um
is there evidence of the fish being
poisoned in the area
there's certainly leachate coming out
and
the the the my understanding of the
consent
um through the this council is that
uh it's an old consent so it doesn't
look at the toxins that maybe
it needs to look at within that area
that but i know
there has been work done in obviously
environment south and have that work but
i'm not sure that it's been published
yeah
yeah it might be interesting to know
that there's a lot of white bayer
white baiters um fishermen that
on the uh oahupai river so that means a
white bait
have to go through that area you're
speaking of and uh up to i hope i to
thompson's wash and there's probably 10
15 20 white
this is leading to a question isn't it
counsellor yeah so there must be
um if they were poisonous the people
wouldn't be eating them
so if if the fish can get through it now
and the problem doesn't escalate it may
be quite safe would it
i think it's down to um college but the
the
toxins that accumulate within the fish
within the estuary
as is a real is a problem uh if and as i
say i haven't got the science in front
of me and i
yeah thank you councillor partner then
council of soper
thank you chair uh richard um with the
leachate
uh is it is it driven by by rain coming
down through the
through the structure and then helping
take stuff out or is it just
leaching without rain there's a tidal
flow into
that area so and because it's not sealed
it's constantly it goes and sucks it out
so that's my next question so
it's at that height of the tide coming
in
i i i haven't got an engineer right now
there is the reason
i mean you mentioned uh with that steed
street bank
the rise is one centimeter a year yeah
so which is significant yeah
and so if it is my question was the
cause of the leak
with no with the with the dump it's more
the tide rising yep
there's a sort of a yes no thanks for
that that makes it that makes it worse
yeah thanks councillor sophie then
councillor arnold
thank you richard um i just want to
check
i presume you're making a similar
submission to environment southland
we we have been talking with environment
south and around the need
for remediation yeah thank you
councillor arnold
um you would have been aware of people
actually fishing
for trout in that area yeah do you have
any feedback on
the quality or state of those fish
because they're catching them and eating
them i believe
that that's probably an issue is the the
the heavy metals and toxins we don't
have the actual report in front of it so
it's been work done but we don't believe
it's been published as yet
um that so that's it's always a
challenge but if
um you know to put our hands up and say
we're all surprised and
in three years time when somebody comes
out with a report about that i don't
think that's probably good enough
yeah no further questions
mr guy thank you very much for your
submission and for coming along this
morning we appreciate it
counselors that brings us to our next
break actually a little early
um there are a couple of light
amendments this afternoon one person
shifting off to tomorrow
and another submitter withdrawing so we
will actually reconvene
at 120. if you can make sure you're
ready to go at 20 past one that would be
appreciated
we are adjourned
[Music]
you